[Music]
our razor sharp claws will cut him and
splatter their foot
we hate to say it but we're disappointed
in you bucky you're supposed to be a
leader but you run and hide whenever
things get spooky we thought you had put
your zombie bullying days behind you but
you were back to the same old
shenanigans in zombies too you might
have allowed zombies to join your cheer
squad but that hasn't stopped you from
sabotaging and segregating them we know
you're a nice guy deep down bucky but
we're still waiting for you to prove it
zombies 2 welcomed a brand new
soundtrack and a band of unique actors
to the franchise with so much going on
it was easy to miss out on some fun
tidbits and background information we're
about to dive into zombies 2 and reveal
the 15 things everyone missed if you
haven't seen the sequel yet keep in mind
that this video contains some major
spoilers you've been warned
i'm so sorry
we got this is the first song we hear in
zombies 2 addison and the cheerleaders
sing it while completing a huge obstacle
course at cheer camp and zed and his
zombie friends join in while dancing
through zombie town but if you hit pause
when zed and the zombies are dancing in
front of the movie theater you can see
that knight of the werewolf is playing
at the cinema is this a coincidence
probably not what's even more curious
however is that the sign next to it is
blurred out could this be the title of
zombies three watch until the end to
find out
i'm so excited to see
well
you know
zed's little sister zoe loves animals
more than anything so we weren't
surprised that she was excited about the
werewolf threat instead of being afraid
zoe even put up a poster saying that she
wanted a werewolf friend that's when
zoey crossed past with wyatt who is
posing as a human after chatting with
wyatt zoe realizes that he's not who
he's pretending to be zoe makes a remark
about the size of wyatt's eyes which
look huge behind his glasses zoe says
what big eyes you have which is a
reference to the european fairy tale
little red riding hood if you notice
this reference leave a wolf emoji in the
comments it was a werewolf
it's no secret that bucky doesn't like
zombies he's made that very clear but
during the musical number we got this we
see just how far bucky will go to
humiliate and harm the zombies at his
school in a blink and you'll miss it
moment we see bucky blasting a z team
cheerleader with his bugzuka which is
like a bazooka but with water we knew
that bucky was mischievous but we never
thought he would physically harm his
cheerleaders the look on the z team's
faces says it all bucky had a bukzuka
made to sabotage the z team but they won
anyway
disappointing
you can't be scared to get those jazz
hands dirty
every sports team needs a mascot which
is why no one batted an eye at the
seabrook high mascot shrimpy but things
get a little weird when it was revealed
that shrimpy also doubled as a bus
driver clearly shrimpy had some issues
keeping his eyes and bus on the road
instead of slamming on the brakes when
he saw zed on the ladder he hit the
zombie and kept driving shrimpy did not
stop driving until the bus collided with
a fence in the forbidden forest so
basically without shrimpy the werewolves
would never have seen addison and
entered seabrook without shrimpy zombies
2 would not have been possible we're
surrounded by werewolves cool
shrimpy's days as a bus driver are
numbered he put everyone's lives at risk
when he failed to bring the bus to a
stop during his rampage we see shrimpy
collide with a fence and on the fence is
a sign that reads forbidden forest keep
out afterward we find out that this vent
was stopping the werewolves from getting
out or the zombies and humans from
getting in but did you notice how small
this fence was what was stopping the
almighty werewolves from jumping over
the fence before shrimpy took it down
and who put up the fence in the first
place we find the girl and if she's the
great alpha she'll tell us where the
moonstone is hidden
there's a lot of mystery surrounding the
forbidden forest and we're hoping to
find out more about it should the
franchise add a third installment did
any of you notice how huge the moon was
when willa and her pack surrounded
addison in the forest not only is the
moon huge and dark but it's also present
despite it being light outside could
this bizarre moon be what powers the
moon stone in the first place and why
can this moon only be seen in the
forbidden forest obviously seabrook is a
town unlike any other so anything is
possible anyway who cares what they
think it's a terrible town
ever since zombietown was allowed to
open its gates tons of new shops have
popped up all over town there's the
night of the living dead store and a
crystal shop too seabrook has come a
long way since the first zombies movie
but they still have a long way to go
after watching zombies 2 we know that
the zombies and werewolves inherited
their special powers from magical
crystals however crystal shops are
usually run by witches could this
crystal shop be hinting towards zombies
3 introducing witches of some sort what
other new stores did you spot in zombie
town in seabrook tell us in the comments
they see one werewolf and we can't go to
prawn
the dog ate my homework is one of the
oldest excuses in the book it's a joke
that's been used plenty of times and it
popped up in zombies 2 in the most
subtle of ways when wyatt is following
addison in the library the camera jumps
to brie who is doing her homework but
then winter pops up behind her rips out
a page from her binder and eats it now
we all know that winter can go a little
overboard with her intimidation tactics
but who eats paper well a dog does we
hope bree's teacher believes her when
she says that that dog just ate my
homework
fans of the first zombies film were
quick to point out that the zombies all
had the letter z in their names while
some zombies like zed and zoe start
their names off with the letter others
like eliza and bonzo simply have a z
inside of their first names well in case
you didn't notice the werewolves follow
a similar naming pattern as the zombies
wyatt willa and winter all have names
that start with the letter w but the
first letter of their names isn't the
only thing that can be linked back to
their werewolf backgrounds willa and
wyatt's last name is lykensen which
derives from the word lycan and lichen
is a term used to describe a humanoid
wolf
i am a mean mean werewolf king
it's pretty common for high schools to
have huge budgets when it comes to
sports but seabrook's cheerleading
budget is out of this world not only is
the town about to knock down seabrook
power to make room for a new
cheerleading platform but it also hosts
a yearly cheer camp the obstacle course
we see during the song we got this must
have cost the town thousands of dollars
to build if not more seabrook high has a
huge budget when it comes to
cheerleading
every adult knows that they have to
watch what they say around children kids
can easily pick up on bad words and
repeat them without fail we saw this
happen when addison was brought to the
den of the wolf when addison is
attempting to howl she says a bunch of
hilarious things but at one point wyatt
stops her to remind her that there are
were pups around winter points out that
addison needs to put a pebble in this
werewolf jar but the damage has been
done all of the young wolves mimic
addison's swear word at the exact same
time did you catch this hilarious joke
she needs to put a pebble in this
werewolf jar
zed and bucky go head to head for the
chance to become the school president
they sing the catchy song i'm winning to
show the crowd why they deserve to win
during the song things get a little
personal bucky points out that zed is a
monster who can't control himself bucky
believes this to be the reason why he
should be elected school president
instead of zed but zed fires back
without a second to waste when bucky
points out that zed eats brains zed says
that bucky has nothing to worry about
since he has none zed called bucky
stupid to his face and it flew right
over his head did you catch this
hilarious insult
oh did you see that that was a high five
there is both good and bad karma
depending on what you put out in the
world unfortunately for zed he did
something bad and received a huge dose
of karma within minutes when zed finds
out that addison might be a werewolf he
steals her necklace to stop her from
transforming but obviously this wasn't
his choice to make after winning over
the crowd during the presidential debate
zed's z-ban clashes with the crystal
necklace which results in zed going full
zombie on the crowd because of this zed
loses the crowd and bucky becomes the
student body president if zed hadn't
stolen addison's necklace he might have
won against bucky
i lost the election
maybe
[Music]
probably
the werewolves might look like high
school students hence why they were
welcome to join sebrakai but these sly
wolves are not who they appear to be
willa wyatt winter and their pack are a
lot older than addison zed and company
they don't age like zombies and humans
do at the beginning of the movie winter
says that once they locate the moonstone
they'll be able to live wolf strong for
another 100 years turns out the
moonstone also provides anti-aging
properties and when we do we can
recharge our necklaces and stay wolf
strong for another 100 years
if you thought the zombies franchise was
over and done with think again although
the disney channel has yet to confirm a
three-quell it's obvious that something
is in the works after all zombies 2 did
end with a cliffhanger we still don't
know which group addison belongs to
she's not a human or a zombie or a
werewolf if we had to guess zombies 3
would finally reveal addison's true
heritage addison's white hair was
glowing bright blue at the end of the
sequel and a blue meteor was seen
falling from the sky there's so much
left to the story and we can't wait to
find out which new couples link up in z3
did anyone else notice the chemistry
between eliza and wyatt sound off in the
comments
we're a strong united and tight-knit
community
the highly anticipated sequel to disney
channel zombies finally aired on
february 14th 2020 zombies 2 was a lot
of fun with new songs and great new
characters want to know how milo manheim
and meg donnelly felt about that
on-screen smooch keep watching to find
out all the behind the scenes secrets we
have a brilliant and cheer-tested
candidate running for president this
year
me
filming a movie is hard work actors
spend long hours on set during filming
they have to film each scene several
times to get it absolutely perfect it's
even more difficult when there are lots
of huge dance numbers like in zombies
too even though filming was a lot of fun
for the cast they had to work really
hard after a full month of rehearsals
they started filming but a lot of the
movie happens at night after all there
are werewolves and zombies in seabrook
they aren't known for hanging out during
the day many of the night scenes took
hours to film even if they were only a
couple of minutes long this led to
overnight filming sessions the cast
would be up all night and sometimes the
cast to just hung around at night if
they weren't in those scenes they really
just enjoyed being with each other meg
hung out when she wasn't needed on
trevor torchman's last day on set but
there are a lot of daytime shots too how
did the cast manage to catch some z's
[Music]
milo manheim plays the world's greatest
zombie as zed he's a great friend
athlete and big brother he's also a
really great dancer milo impressed
everyone with his dance moves in the
first movie but then he impressed the
rest of the world when he appeared on
dancing with the stars in 2018 milo was
paired with professional dancer whitney
carson the pair came in second place on
the show milo showed off his new dance
moves behind the scenes of zombies too
according to meg and his other co-stars
he solves us every five seconds
it's great
meg told j14 magazine that she thinks
his dance moves got even better after
being on the competition show but that
didn't stop her from teasing him in
milo's behind the scenes video he said
meg likes to do an impression of his
dance moves it was pretty hilarious but
he got her back these two best friends
aren't afraid to tease each other a
little it's all in good fun oh oh hey um
hey i'm milo and i'm meg
from everything the cast is said it
sounds like zombies 2 was a blast to
film it really helps when they are all
great friends j14 magazine sat down with
mcdonnelly pierce jose arielle martin
and chandler kinney they asked megan the
new actors about their funniest moments
on set apparently they all spent their
time laughing trevor tordsman who plays
bucky is apparently one of the funniest
members of the cast he likes to riff and
improv when he's off camera meg would
cry from laughing so hard trevor has
great comedic timing meg also thought
that it was hilarious watching everyone
dive into the mud for the song we got
this it was funny for the fans too
another hilarious moment behind the
scenes happened at dance rehearsals in
the last week of rehearsals the werewolf
dancers had to get used to dancing in
their wigs so they came to practice in
normal clothes and makeup while wearing
giant werewolf wigs the actors said it
looked so funny since no one else was in
costume
[Applause]
one of the most powerful scenes in
zombies 2 is the dance number for flesh
and bones this song was amazing it was
all about standing up for yourself and
loving yourself for who you are we're
all more than flesh and bones the song
also had some deep political messages
too milo mannheim revealed that this
song means the most to him out of all of
them it's a really emotional song his
character zed has a lot of fear he
realizes that he hates being a monster
which he takes out on addison he has to
get over that milo said that flesh and
bones was the turning point for his
character that's when zed realizes that
the werewolves are more than just
monsters and so is he he really turns
his attitude around after that and fixes
his bad decisions we can really see his
character turn it around too milo poured
all of his emotions into that number
you're fierce proud werewolves yeah they
think we're monsters
we are monsters
every time we see a cast in an interview
they act like they are all best friends
but it's more than acting the cast of
zombies is really close how did they get
to be such good friends the answer is
game night in the first movie the cast
often had dance parties together they
continued that tradition but added a
bunch of board games to the mix they all
stayed at the same hotel so they would
get together and play games they started
this from the very beginning of
rehearsals everyone talks about how much
fun these nights were the number one
game that they played was bananagrams
the cast also had pool parties honestly
it sounds like filming zombies 2 was a
blast if they were not playing games or
spending time at the pool they were
always hanging out they'd even go to the
grocery store together just to get some
snacks the original cast welcomed the
new werewolves into the fold right away
meg invited pierce to hang out the very
first night they met they were in the
elevator and she asked if he was coming
to her room to hang out he was a little
taken aback but he joined the rest of
the cast he was part of the pack from
that night on
i knew they didn't have to be loud you
just you oh
one of the themes from the first movie
was standing out from the status quo
seabrook was all about conformity that
theme of individuality continued on in
zombies too but when you're filming
choreographed dance numbers it's hard to
be an individual everyone is doing the
same moves right not in zombies two the
choreographers and directors wanted
everyone's personality to shine through
the dance numbers they have the same
basic moves but they were free to add
their own personal spin everyone had
their own variation that made these
dance numbers even better this personal
touch extended into the costuming
department the werewolves didn't fit in
with the humans or the zombies they are
totally unique so pierce arielle and
chandler got to have input in their
costumes they had to wear certain items
but then they were allowed to spice it
up for their characters we love how much
artistic expression the actors were able
to uphold zed and addison finally kissed
in zombies too but filming this
on-screen pack wasn't easy keep watching
for all the details
[Music]
it can be daunting to be the new kid on
the block arielle martin said that she
had a lot of anxiety about joining the
cast she knew how close-knit everyone
was and then she had a delay when
getting to toronto for rehearsals she
showed up three days late which made her
feel even more anxious she was worried
about not knowing the choreography and
how everyone would treat her but she
didn't have to worry at all when she
arrived meg texted her to welcome her to
canada arielle told 17 magazine that
that helped a lot she got to rehearsals
early the next day and ran into chandler
pierce and meg they showed her the
choreography that she missed so she
wouldn't fall behind the next day
arielle joined them for her first game
night once they spent time hanging out
she no longer felt worried about fitting
in it definitely helped that her
co-stars were so nice and helpful our
pack is our pack
we don't need anyone else so
it wasn't just the older cast members
that would hang out together it can be
hard to be younger than a lot of people
on set kingston foster who plays zoe in
the movies is only 9 years old most of
her co-stars are in their teens or early
20s but they didn't make her feel left
out at all kingston bonded really well
with the werewolf actresses arielle and
chandler she had a girls night with them
they baked cookies from scratch and had
a ton of fun she also said that they
would play a game where there were spies
on set we think it's great that the
older actors worked hard to include
kingston and who can blame them she's an
awesome kid that's it we're going
when you're playing a werewolf you need
a lot of makeup and sometimes stage
makeup can be a real hassle pierce jose
who plays wyatt said that his makeup
test took seven hours for the test they
try to figure out what works and what
doesn't and creating a werewolf takes a
long time he spent literally a whole day
in the makeup chair while the makeup
artists work their magic it didn't take
7 hours every time but putting on the
werewolf makeup still took a couple of
hours every day pierce also got freaked
out by the acrylic nails he was having a
rough day and hadn't eaten he didn't
realize that they glued giant acrylics
on your nails before they trim them he
said he nearly passed out when he saw
how long they were and what about those
glowing werewolf eyes often actors will
wear colored contacts but not everyone
can handle them the movie avoided that
issue altogether the creepy eyes were
all added in post-production by video
editors
[Music]
okay this is a little bit weird
fans were so excited that zed and
addison finally had their first kiss it
was so sweet and romantic but they were
just acting there's nothing romantic
about filming this sort of scene milo
and meg are best friends in real life
thankfully that made them feel relaxed
instead of awkward but the logistics of
kissing on screen are difficult it has
to look perfect on camera meg said that
they probably kissed about eight times
to get it just right in one take her
nose looked squished in another his face
was almost entirely covering hers they
had to work hard to line up their lips
to get the perfect shot yeah that's
definitely not romantic it may have
taken them several tries but they
finally got it their on-screen smooch
was perfect even though it was one of
the last scenes in the movie it was shot
the first weekend of filming they got it
out of the way so it wasn't looming over
them we go tonight you've been the alpha
for so long willa it's hard to imagine
you letting go of the position without a
fight but luckily you didn't have to
step down as number one you had your
doubts about addison from the start but
she proved you wrong in the right kind
of way you might come off as mean and
tough but willa your bark is worse than
your bite we hope to see more of you in
zombies 3 if that ever happens too much
perfect
zombies 2 had a fresh storyline an
amazing soundtrack and a pack of new and
wild characters the disney channel
sequel had it all movie mistakes
included we have 10 mistakes from
zombies 2 lined up for you but before we
start we'd like to point out that this
video contained some major spoilers so
keep watching at your discretion if
you're all up to date watch until the
end to find out which huge mistake
disproves the alpha wolf legend
when we first meet addison in zombies
she's ashamed of her natural hair color
causing her to cover it up with a wig
but by the end of the film she's ready
to come clean about her hair color so
she takes off her wig that's when we see
that addison's hair is collar bone
length however come zombies 2 addison's
hair seems to have grown three times as
fast as it should have zombies 2 picks
up at seabrook high after a
groundbreaking semester so basically
only a semester has passed since we
first saw zed and addison fall in love
on the small screen who would have ever
thought that a zombie
can change the world and have their
happily ever after but if that's the
case how did addison's hair grow so
quickly according to healthline hair
grows an average of 6 inches every year
but addison's grew over six inches in
just under three months since addison's
hair is very different than everyone
else's it may grow at a faster rate
however this was never explained and
it's being seen as a continuity error
watch and learn snowball
ah yes my hair
when the town of seabrook finds out that
werewolves are real they panic and
choose to restore the monster law half
of the town is put under curfew while
the other residents are too afraid to
leave their house willa and her pack
choose to sneak their way into seabrook
high where they can locate the
white-haired alpha in the morning but to
do this they have to keep a low profile
or else they risk getting caught the
pack dances their way into seabrook high
where they take refuge in a vent the
great alpha's near but this scene had a
few mistakes that didn't go unnoticed by
eagle eye fans first of all how did
willow wyatt winter and the pack get
into the school last time we checked
schools were locked at night especially
during monster curfews and most
curiously how did the entire pack manage
to fit behind an air vent in the hallway
seeing the wolves walk into the vent was
like watching clowns casually stroll out
of a clown car focus remember we're
fierce
midway through zombies 2 zed catches
wyatt and addison sharing a special
moment which leads him to say things he
doesn't mean according to zed werewolves
they're not interested in fitting in and
according to addison zed is trying to
fit in so badly he's forgetting who he
truly is zed lashes out on addison says
the girl who wore a wig her whole life
this leads to a heartfelt duet called
gotta find where i belong which is sung
by zed and addison who have just fought
for the first time but something a
little strange happens during this duet
we see addison walking through a hallway
wearing her cheerleader uniform but
seconds later when she turns the corner
and walks out of school she's wearing a
light blue outfit instead while it's
normal for outfit changes to occur the
song seem to be unfolding in real time
causing viewers to raise an eyebrow or
two at addison's spontaneous new outfit
we spotted more than one mistake and
gotta find where i belong but more on
that later come with us
what's so important
it's a well-known fact that werewolves
and silver don't mix however there are a
few inconsistencies surrounding this
ancient fact in zombies too while
walking through the seabrook high trophy
hall willow winter and wyatt reveal that
wolves aren't scared of anything except
silver yes silver the ticks
and rabies but then you can see a
werewolf in the background grab hold of
a silver trophy and start screaming when
it burns his hands this doesn't sound
like something a scared werewolf would
do so we figured that disney wanted
viewers to know just how detrimental
silver could be to werewolves problem is
near the end of the film the wolves are
handcuffed after being sprayed with a
thick veil of silver smoke dale reveals
that he sprayed them with collodial
silver and claims that it will tame them
which it does but here's the problem why
didn't the silver smoke burn the wolves
like the trophy did being sprayed by a
liquid with silver attribute should have
given the wolves some serious burns but
it never did if it's gonna hurt the
werewolves you have to stop it you're
right
when we first reunite with zed and
addison they reveal that seabrook and
zombietown have united forces to create
a brand new civilization however
everything falls apart when it's
announced that werewolves are on the
loose seabrook chooses to reinstate the
monster law preventing zombies from
going to prawn and upholding their human
rights but wait did anyone else think it
was strange that willa and her pack were
accepted into zebra kai with open arms
despite the monster law still being in
effect this is not about politics i
always just felt like cheer could unite
we mean the whole reason the monster law
was reinstated in the first place was
because werewolves were in town and yet
they were allowed to join the school no
questions asked it just doesn't add up
what's even weirder is that principal
lee didn't even get a choice in the
matter addison and coach decided to
welcome the wolves without ever
consulting her how could monsters join
the local high school when the monster
law was in full swing can you explain
this movie mistake sound off in the
comments now everything is just being
handed to the werewolves on a silver
platter
brie is addison's best friend and she
has a huge crush on bonzo who likes her
back problem is bonzo doesn't seem to
speak english whereas brie shouldn't be
able to understand a word coming out of
bonzo's mouth but as it turns out bonzo
and brie have no problem communicating
during zombies 2 zed suggests that
seabrook high teach the students how to
speak zombie zombie tongue taught as a
second language good so we know that
it's not on the curriculum so how does
brie understand the zombie language she
could have learned how to speak zombie
on her own since she does have a crush
on bonzo but how did she master the
language so quickly when bonzo asks brie
to attend the prawn with him she says
yes without missing a beat did anyone
else find this strange keep watching for
the biggest mistake in zombies too
bundle's got an ear for languages
addison zed and the wolves go to extreme
lengths to save the moonstone from being
destroyed in the power plant explosion
sadly the seabrook power plant
accidentally explodes after they win the
fight the wolves are immediately
affected and many of them fall ill when
zed visits the wolves hideout he sees
firsthand how the explosion is affecting
them many of them are so sick they can't
even stand they were wrong to destroy
seabrook power but this rule doesn't
apply to willa and wyatt despite their
powers coming from the same energy
source willa and wyatt are seen standing
upright and helping their packmates
still they decide to go to prawn and
have a good time this plot hole isn't
super obvious but the more we think
about it the less it makes sense
wouldn't willa and wyatt be just as sick
as the other wolves and why would willa
who is seen as the alpha leave her pack
behind when they need her the most
there's not enough of us
earlier on in this video we mentioned
that there was two mistakes in the duet
gotta find where i belong the first one
revolves around addison's spontaneous
outfit change and the second one takes
place near the end of the song when day
turns to night in the blink of an eye
addison starts singing the two minute
song while she's still at school but by
the time the song comes to an end it's
dark outside could it be that zed and
addison's duet defies the hands of time
like their relationship defies social
standards even when protesting for
what's right
you bring people together it sure seems
like it or perhaps time isn't as linear
in seabrook as it is in real life this
could explain the time jump that takes
place in gotta find where i belong as
well as the mystery behind addison's
hair growth by the way i love this new
look
new hairstylist
one of the biggest mistakes in zombies 2
revolves around the magical moonstone
throughout the sequel willow reveals
that without the moonstone werewolves
will stop existing however when the
moonstone is destroyed in the power
plant explosion the werewolves fall ill
instead of disappearing but the biggest
mistake of all is exposed when the moon
stone reveals itself to addison and the
wolves midway through prawn the students
find out that the moon stone has not
been destroyed we have to get to it
quickly but we still can the wolves are
then able to recharge their crystals and
cure themselves but if the moonstone was
never destroyed in the first place why
did all the wolves get sick at the exact
same time it could be that the placebo
effect came into play the wolves thought
the moonstone had been destroyed so
their bodies tricked them into feeling
sick what do you guys think was this a
major plot hole or not so it's only
buried and not destroyed
zombies 2 was amazing but there's one
last mistake that we just can't shake
and it has everything to do with the
legend of the great alpha ever since the
wolves saw addison's white hair at the
beginning of the movie they believed her
to be the great alpha you are a leader
addison but of something a lot greater
than cheer according to them there's a
prophecy that states that an alpha
werewolf will lead the wolves to the
moonstone however when addison finally
tries on the werewolf necklace it
doesn't light up for her so basically
she's not a werewolf still she is the
one who led the wolves to the moonstone
so if addison isn't the alpha wolf
there's a huge mistake surrounding the
legend of the great alpha i thought
everything would make sense if i was a
werewolf could it be that addison really
is a werewolf but that zed z band
supercharged her necklace preventing it
from lining up or could the prophecy be
wrong sound off in the comments and be
sure to tell us if you spotted any more
mistakes in zombies too they think we're
monsters
we are monsters today's the first day we
can attend human high school hey zed we
are so glad that you finally were
accepted by the residents of seabrook we
know you didn't have an easy life as a
zombie but now you have friends and an
awesome girlfriend i thought that you
wanted to go first
so
okay that's my excuse
we heard there are some new kids coming
to seabrook high and we have to wonder
how are you and addison going to handle
the werewolves all right that wasn't
that bad
[Music]
will you accept them immediately or is
it going to take some time werewolves
are coming to seabrook in zombies too
and we are so excited here is everything
you need to know about the new
werewolves when disney channel announced
that we're getting a sequel to zombies
we were so pumped we are back because we
are shooting zombies
but we were left wondering what the
movie is going to be about the end of
the first movie was pretty perfect
addison and zed convinced everyone in
seabrook that their biases against
zombies were wrong they proved that
zombies are just people too they just
happen to like brains for dinner addison
revealed that she isn't like everyone
else either everyone is different and
seabrook learned how to celebrate those
differences the segregation of zombie
town ended and the zombies were fully
accepted life seemed pretty perfect i
can feel the energy coursing through my
bones right now it's awesome so what on
earth will happen in zombies 2 to upset
the new dynamic the answer is werewolves
according to disney channel werewolves
are coming to seabrook and not everyone
is going to welcome them with open arms
this isn't surprising it took decades
for seabrook to accept zombies they have
only just learned how to be open and
accepting and the arrival of a whole new
type of supernatural people is going to
challenge the residents of the town and
it's going to cause a rift between dead
and addison these two have already had a
challenging relationship we wonder how
they will overcome this new problem
zombies 2 takes place a year after the
first movie everything is going pretty
well for the zombies and the humans it's
not perfect but everyone is learning to
live together then a pack of werewolves
arrives you can't show them that as a
surprise
three of these wolves are teenagers who
will attend seabrook high the werewolves
are wyatt willa and winter wyatt and
willow are brother and sister winter is
a member of their pack we don't know
much yet about their lives as werewolves
can they turn into wolves whenever or is
it just at the full moon we can't wait
to find out we also know that they
aren't the only werewolves coming to
seabrook there is one other werewolf
listed in the cast so far his title is
just werewolf dancer 12. that means
there are at least 11 other werewolf
dancers wyatt willa and winter are just
the main three werewolves that the movie
will focus on it's also possible that
we'll meet adult members of their pack
since we know some of the human and
zombie adults too you don't have to
change who you are son i love who you
are who is playing the werewolves winter
the werewolf is played by ariel martin
you might know her better as baby ariel
ariel is a singer actress and social
media influencer and we are so excited
that she is joining the disney channel
family recently ariel has been acting on
the brat shows chicken girls and baby
doll records she plays drew ariel first
became famous from the app musically she
had millions of followers because she is
just so talented so i've just really
been myself all these years i've been
doing it for three years in 2016 and
2017 she won the teen choice award for
choice muser time magazine and forbes
have recognized her as one of the most
influential young people in
entertainment she is going to be amazing
in zombies too wyatt is played by pierce
jose pierce has been at disney channel
for a few years he appeared on a few
episodes of lab rats in 2016. he has
also been playing spider-johnson on mech
x4 for the last couple of years you
might also recognize him from legendary
dudas on nickelodeon pierce is only 17
years old but he already has an
impressive career his family moved to
los angeles in 2015 so he could pursue
his passions it didn't take long for him
to get picked up by hollywood we can't
wait to see him sing and dance in
zombies too chandler kinney plays willa
chandler is one of the stars of the tv
show lethal weapon in 2014 she appeared
in several episodes of the nickelodeon
show the haunted hathaways then she left
to star in gordamore gibbons life on
normal street as catherine chandler
began dancing at age three set the path
necessary to like achieve their goals
she's also trained in martial arts which
she started learning when she was 10
years old she was just 13 when she
earned her first degree black belt we
wonder if any of those martial arts
skills will appear in zombies too
zombies two theories we know that the
werewolves are going to cause a rift in
addison and zed's relationship but who
is going to have a bigger problem with
werewolves it could be addison she was
quick to accept zombies in the first
movie but she knew that zombies existed
her whole life they lived in another
part of town plus she fell in love with
zed werewolves could be extra scary and
threatening to her or maybe it's dead he
knows what it's like to not be accepted
but often supernatural creatures have a
lot of prejudice against each other
zombies and werewolves could be sworn
enemies he might also feel like wyatt is
threatening his relationship with
addison what do you think will happen in
zombies too let us know in the comments
welcome back
we were so excited to find out that you
were returning for zombies too megan
donnelly you were so great as addison in
the first movie we are so pumped to see
you and milo back in seabrook you
changed the world through cheer but we
got to wondering are you and your
castmates really high school students
and we know that we ship addison and zed
but who are you two dating in real life
we want all the deets you can't show
them that as a surprise we love the
entire cast of zombies too and we have
their real ages and relationships lined
up for you so don't go anywhere you
won't believe who meg donnelly is
rumored to be dating in real life milo
manheim the star of the zombies
franchise is zombie zed he's a football
playing zombie who is totally in love
with addison well how would you know
you're perfect milo manheim is 18 years
old in real life he used to date holiday
kriegel but they split in october of
2018. there have been rumors that he is
dating his dancing with the stars
partner alexis wren the two are
definitely close but neither of them
have confirmed a relationship emilia
mccarthy we know her best as the
seabrook high cheerleader lacey she
eventually comes around and decides
zombies aren't that bad this isn't good
bucky what are you doing lacey is played
by amelia mccarthy amelia is definitely
not a high schooler in real life she is
22 years old amelia has been acting for
a while she is currently single and
focusing on her career it looks like she
has dated in the past but she keeps her
private life under wraps chandler kinney
one of the new cast members is chandler
kinney she is playing a werewolf named
willa chandler has been on the lethal
weapon tv show you'd be surprised she
also appeared in one episode of girl
meets world in real life chandler is 19
years old if chandler has dated anyone
she has certainly kept her private life
private there's no news about any
current or past relationships carla
jeffrey addison's bff brie is returning
for zombies too brie was an aspiring
cheerleader who became addison's friend
in the first movie
she is played by carla jeffrey she might
look young but carla is actually 26
years old wow we never would have
guessed carla has managed to keep her
personal life a secret so we don't know
if she's involved with anyone right now
pierce jose
next is another new character pierce
joseph plays wyatt one of the werewolves
who comes to seabrook you might know
pierce as spider johnson from the tv
show mech x4 you know what maybe it's
friendly i'm sorry i shot at you he was
on the show for two years pierce is just
17 years old in real life that's right
he is one of the seabrook high students
who is currently of high school age
pierce is currently living the single
life trevor torchman you know him as
bucky from the first zombies movie he
was the head cheerleader and he hated
zombies we like to remind zombies that
we don't accept freaks in this town his
character was also addison's cousin
which made things even more complicated
trevor torchman is back in the second
movie trevor is on a canadian tv show
about dancers called the next step for
over 120 episodes in real life trevor is
23 years old he is currently single
kingston foster
dad's little zombie sister is zoe we
loved her character and we were so glad
she finally got the dog she always
wanted my very own puppy we can't wait
to see her again in zombies too kingston
is just nine years old she is certainly
getting more and more awesome roles
since she's so young kingston definitely
is not dating anyone we are so excited
to see her grow up and do awesome things
kylie russell eliza is one of zed's
awesome zombie best friends and she is
one of the best characters in the movie
yeah we would have cleaned but the
teacher's territorial about his mop
eliza is played by kylie russell she has
been a disney channel star for a long
time she appeared in the original movie
jump in way back in 2007 she is 23 years
old in real life kylie has been dating
samuel hoser since 2016 and they are
seriously couple goals james godfrey zed
and eliza's other bff is bonzo and we
just love his character
bonzo is played by james godfrey you
might also know him from the disney
movie the swap zombies was james's first
real big role and he did great he's no
teenager like his character james is 22
years old he is currently not dating
anyone jasmine renee thomas
stacy was one of the cheerleaders in
zombies and she is back in zombies too
stacy is played by jasmine renee thomas
playing stacy was her first major role
stage two initiated appreciated she is
25 years old stacey is trained as both a
dancer and a gymnast she started lessons
when she was just two years old if
jasmine is currently dating anyone she
is keeping it on the down low ariel
martin the third werewolf is winter and
she is played by ariel martin you might
also know her as baby ariel she got her
start as a singer on the musically app
and gained a huge following but how do
you get 40 million people following you
i mean i honestly don't know she also
played drew on the brat shows chicken
girls and baby doll records ariel is
just 18 years old in real life she has
dated blake grey and zach clayton but
she is currently single meg donnelly
addison is everyone's favorite
cheerleader we just love her character
this is our revolution okay but does it
have to be cheer though come on she is
played by the talented meg donnelly meg
has also been acting on the show
american housewife for the last three
years megan is 19 years old she's very
private about her personal life but
there are rumors she is dating logan
pepper she is also real life besties
with her co-star milo manheim who is
your favorite character from zombies let
us know in the comment section
all i've ever wanted is to find my pack
zombies 2 was the perfect sequel with
great new characters and catchy new
songs but it ended with a huge
cliffhanger does this mean that zombies
3 is happening keep watching to find out
i think i may be a werewolf too what how
let's do a quick recap of everything
that happened in zombies 2. we find out
that werewolves used to rule the land
around seabrook their moonstone and home
were stolen by the settlers these days
life in seabrook seems pretty happy
zombies are fully integrated and mostly
accepted addison is at cheer camp and
there are even zombies on the cheer
squad she leads the newbies to victory
zedd plans an epic invitation to prawn
but it goes awry when the bus full-on
hits him seriously who lets a shrimp
mascot drive a bus they end up in the
forbidden forest where addison sees the
werewolves
we're not alone we're surrounded by
werewolves cool this puts seabrook in a
panic and addison's mom reinstates all
anti-monster laws preventing zed from
going to the prawn the werewolves need
to find the moonstone and recharge their
gems otherwise they won't survive wyatt
thinks addison's white hair is a sign
she is the great alpha who will save
them all zed runs for school president
against bucky and addison has a chance
to become cheer captain she thinks she
might be a werewolf and joins their pack
she and zed have a huge fight because he
doesn't want her to be a monster he
tries to pass as human because he thinks
that's how zombies will be accepted
everyone unites and saves the moonstone
and the werewolves recharge their
necklaces zed and addison make up and
finally lock lips at prawn the zombies
realize that being monsters is what
makes them special
because i couldn't accept the fact that
i am one
after the prawn addison is fast asleep
in her bed we hear what sounds like an
explosion outside her window something
like a blue meteor crashes to the ground
outside of seabrook addison wakes up
because her clock radio is going crazy
with static and music she looks at the
camera and says weird then her hair
glows blue the movie ends on this huge
cliffhanger what does it mean we know
that addison's hair is significant in
the first movie it just made her
different in zombies 2 she thinks it
might mean she's a werewolf but now that
her white hair can glow we have so many
questions my hair means something
zombies 2 was just released on february
14th 2020. they are still riding the
wave of the new release so they haven't
officially announced a three-qual
however there is a huge chance we will
get a zombies three and most fans agree
that the cliffhanger guarantees that it
will happen there is a lot of other
evidence to suggest that we'll get a
third movie too first up disney channel
wasn't sure if zombies 2 would happen so
they didn't end the first movie on a
cliffhanger everything wrapped up neatly
just in case the movie wasn't a success
but it was a huge hit if they weren't
sure about zombies 3 they wouldn't have
ended the movie the way they did ending
on addison and zed's romantic scene
would have been perfect the zombies
franchise also has a couple of
precedents on disney channel sometimes
original movies stand alone but their
most successful films often turn into
trilogies the xenon franchise had three
movies halloweentown had four and in the
last 14 years disney channel has had
great success with huge musical movies
high school musical is the top disney
channel original movie franchise of all
time this musical had two sequels then
descendants happened these movies were
such a huge success they had great
characters and even better music
descendants also became a three movie
franchise zombies has a lot in common
with those two big musicals there are
edgy musical numbers and awesome dance
scenes and like descendants zombies has
epic like story lines it's fantasy so
it's pretty common that it requires
multiple movies so when will zombies 3
happen zombies 2 wasn't even announced
until a full year before it came out we
can expect a confirmation from disney
channel in early 2021 filming for both
movies occurred in the spring and early
summer before its release that means the
cast probably won't head back to toronto
until spring of next year zombies 2 came
out two years after the first one so we
can expect to see zombies 3 in 2022 and
disney always releases its sequels
around the same time of year since the
first two were both released in february
we're probably looking at february of
2022 maybe they'll rename the school
after me one day
what cast members will return so far no
one has said they don't want to come
back most of the principal cast seems
open to a third movie and who can blame
them filming it look like so much fun
and they're all such close friends milo
manheim who plays zed has confirmed that
he is definitely interested in telling
the next part of the story disney will
also probably bring back the same
director paul hohen he's done a lot of
great movies for the disney channel and
the two other big musical trilogies kept
the same directors paul will make sure
the third movie feels like the others
the werewolves are now an important part
of seabrook they have expressed interest
in returning too
[Applause]
[Music]
we also know that zombies three will
have a similar theme and message zombies
dealt with accepting others who are
different it was an important message
about prejudice and how it hurts
everyone zombies too continued this
theme but took it to the next level
zed showed that sometimes we have
internalized prejudices about ourselves
this is common in marginalized
communities he had to learn to accept
that what makes him different makes him
special and both movies had strong
themes of individuality and belonging
they teach us that we should be
ourselves and that we can still belong
without conforming but addison still
feels like an outsider she wants to find
her pack we're sure to see these themes
pop up again in zombies 3.
they think we're monsters
we are monsters
so what could zombies 3 be about there
are a ton of possible plot lines that we
would love to see explored the first has
to do with addison and her true identity
in the first two movies addison is
really focused on helping other people
sure she wants to be a cheerleader and
the true captain but the main point of
the first movie was helping the zombies
in the second movie she wanted to help
the werewolves it's about time we get a
movie that is really all about addison
the cliffhanger makes us think this is
probably the case a meteor crashing from
outer space is a pretty good indicator
that aliens will be involved was it a
meteor or was it a spaceship it would
definitely be on brand for there to be a
new outsider in seabrook we will also
find out why addison's hair is so
important the thing that crashed caused
her hair to glow blue but what does that
mean it has to be more significant than
just identifying her as an alien right
does addison have special powers that
would be really cool but the movie would
need to explore why these powers just
now popped up it must have something to
do with whatever crashed they must be
testing charges for the demolition
tomorrow let's talk more about the crash
there is the possibility that it is a
spaceship full of aliens if addison is
an alien what does that mean about her
parents addison could have secretly been
adopted if that's the case her parents
have some serious explaining to do what
if they let her think she was different
for her entire life without ever coming
clean and then made her cover up her
hair to look like the perfect daughter
anyway if there are aliens in seabrook
there could be addison's real parents
they might be coming back to find her
will addison want to be with them or
with the parents who raised her is it
possible that she would choose to leave
seabrook to learn about who she really
is that would be so sad addison might
also be a half alien one of her parents
could secretly be from outer space for
some reason they're trying to pass as
human maybe they got stuck here or maybe
they're on some mission by order of city
council effective immediately all
anti-monster laws are
reinstated but what if there is no
spaceship maybe the meteor that fell is
something else entirely remember
seabrook became prosperous because of
its special energy source seabrook power
was destroyed in zombies too the
werewolves reclaimed the moon zone so
they could charge their necklaces and
save their lives seabrook might need a
new source of energy it's possible that
without seabrook power harnessing the
power of the moonstone seabrook is
struggling the meteor could be a new
source of energy for the town there's
another possibility for it too remember
how eliza had a theory about zombies
evolving she thinks they might not need
their z bands anymore it's true that
zedd was able to control himself from
attacking and he was able to put the z
band back on but what if the meteor is
actually a way for zombies to fully
integrate they can keep their zombie
strength without endangering the people
around them eliza's comment was too
significant to ignore we think zombies
evolving could come into play in the
third movie milo mannheim has his own
theory about zombies three and we have
to admit it's a good one zed and zoe
live with their dad who became a foreman
overseeing the demolition of seabrook
power he's a great dad and zed and his
sister are both really happy but what
happened to their mom fans asked this
after the first movie they have to have
a mom right but she has never mentioned
milo said again that no one knows what
happened to her is she even alive who
knows he said that sometimes the cast
would talk about it and come up with
their own theories he suggests that
finding out what happened to their mom
should be a plot point in the third
movie there's a huge age difference
between zed and zoe so zed has to
remember his mom it's possible that she
went missing maybe she escaped zombie
town and seabrook she might have gone
looking for a cure to help all of the
zombies or she might have just gotten
tired of being segregated but what if
she has something to do with the crash
from outer space maybe addison and her
abilities are part of a cure for the
zombies it would be cool if zed's mom
got help from an alien civilization then
zombies wouldn't have to wear their
bands anymore they can have powers
without losing their minds we really
want to know what happened to zed's mom
and that's a wrap let us know your
zombies three theories in the comments
section when you put it on you'll be
transformed into a werewolf
thanks for watching hit that subscribe
button and give us a big thumbs up see
you next time on the things
[Music]